[Aplausos]
[Música]
las oportunidades que te da la vida
siendo médico veterinario
alucinante que está la oportunidad que
me ha dado de estar acá yo siempre veo y
busco oportunidad oportunidades en la
vida y tomo decisiones
me encantó escuchar superpoder todos
tenemos superpoderes mi superpoder es el
médico veterinario esta frase se la
escuché a un referente todos tenemos que
tener referentes en la vida
césar moral es un crack y odio de ellos
de aquellos fenómenos que la medicina
veterinaria en latinoamérica nos dio le
escuche a él
superpoder y me puse a analizar
cuando yo era chico
vamos a escuchar también muchos
referentes que he tenido en mi vida uno
de ellos está ahí mi viejo
cuando yo era chico de una vez clínica
humanos
me llevaron a una clínica veterinaria
así de real yo respiraba siempre respire
veterinaria
yo veía a mi viejo
como un superhéroe no todos vemos a
nuestros padres y los chequea galería y
decía guau como salvavidas cuando yo sea
grande
quiero ser como él
quiero tener ese superpoder
no no vayan a pensar que esta mochila
que cargo es porque me haya olvidado o
seguro que muchos de los que me conocen
dirán y pancho se olvidó de bajar la
mochila esto es parte de mi charla es
una mochila que cargo
él es mi viejo un gran referente
respire veterinaria
ingrese
a la facultad de medicina veterinaria de
la decana de américa san marcos ahí tuve
la suerte otra oportunidad que me dio la
vida tuve la suerte de
saber de qué se trata la medicina
veterinaria para mí no hay dudas si no
queremos que ocurra otra pandemia
tienen que estar los médicos
veterinarios involucrados en el concepto
de salud
tiene que regirse en un solo eje la
salud el ambiente la salud de los
animales y el humano en un solo eje si
no queremos que ocurran nuevas pandemias
no hemos aprendido nada en 100 años sin
embargo
la pandemia pasada nos hizo lo mismo sin
como veterinario yo entendí ese concepto
de una salud no lo entiendo por ejemplo
se habla del pcr hace muchísimos años
que nosotros hablamos y tratamos y
manejamos el pcr las pruebas sí
nosotros los veterinarios vemos todo lo
que cocinan los chefs gastón
sí que es otro referente mío los
veterinarios vemos lo que comen los
humanos esto está bien pero puedes comer
los veterinarios somos importantes en
salud pública no los veterinarios no
solo curamos perros y gatos que es donde
yo
me desenvuelvo en terminado como este
sin embargo
y los veterinarios
a veces no estamos
bien valorados como profesionales
en el planeta la humanidad
creo que podemos dar muchísimo más en la
universidad yo fui una persona muy
inquieta disperso
me costó la carrera de cinco años y
medio yo la hice en nueve años y medio
todos decían muy pobre cabello miren el
hijo que le tocó uff
terrible era de los inquietos realmente
los que me conocen saben cómo pero yo no
me arrepiento de nada
he disfrutado y mucha experiencia y me
dio la oportunidad de saber clarísimo
que los veterinarios somos
importantísimos para el humanidad
una salud la salud del medio ambiente de
los animales y el humano se debe manejar
en un solo eje
ahora después del documental que hubo
este los hongos
hablemos de esa luz planetaria porque
los hongos es otro reino pero ese es
otro tema
la traumatología
yo sabía que tenía un superpoder mi
viejo tenía ese superpoder soy
veterinario y quería ser el mejor
traumatólogo los sueños existen a ojo yo
siempre los percibo siempre busca
oportunidades hoy tengo una gran
oportunidad
la traumatología me llevó a conocer
muchísimas cosas de la capacidad que yo
tenía
pero un problema
para especializarte en esa época yo
tengo 48 años
tenías que irte o a europa o eeuu
y nació en mi hijo fabricio no me pude
ir a españa yo me voy de españa
probablemente
y valorar ese sueño de ser el mejor
traumatólogo del mundo
no logré irme
y se me cruzaron muchos perritos muchas
ideas muchas frustraciones
y ahí fue que dije yo voy a hacer el
mejor trato logo
definitivamente donde consigo la
casuística para especializarme si no me
puedo ir porque quiero ver a mi hijo
crecer quiero estar acá a los perros de
la calle
la mayoría son jóvenes si es que no son
todos porque
porque los atropellan mueren
atropellados
desamparados dije ah ahí
me especializo ahí tengo la casuística
desarrollé implantes desarrollé un
montón de cosas un montón de cosas de
tecnología y se publicaban revistas
científicas
en todos lados empecé a hacerme un
nombre no tenía el peso pesado de mi
viejo y emitió somos una familia
veterinaria y encontré la casuística que
estaba buscando y así
empezó una nueva ruta y seguía en ese
sueño ser el mejor reumatólogo yo soñaba
en vivir en un quirófano
en esos tiempos
también quería ser el mejor neurólogo y
ahí otro referente más bob feller
si me estás escuchando ese también es un
momento de agradecer no hay que
agradecer eso es algo que todo el mundo
lo habla ese es parte de mi secreto hoy
le estoy agradeciendo a esos referentes
sobre todo los que soy mencionando a vos
el ser y hay una curiosidad el que me
enseñó muchísimo en neurología y aprendí
alucinantemente al final
sin juicio
detalle que la vida empezó a marcar no
es decir hojas que está pasando acá
dice la silla de ruedas
porque quería que la gente sepa que yo
estaba haciendo cirugías de columna aquí
en el perú la vedette fue la silla de
ruedas llegó hasta magaly teve pasó por
todos lados y lo que más importó fue las
jie ruedas que lo que se estaba haciendo
en cirugías lo decía este pechito está
haciendo cirugías bueno la silla de
ruedas
empezó a darme un poquito de esa fama y
empezó a conectarme con esa camarita que
está allí no y me di cuenta que los
sueños pueden cambiar
para solo el terremoto pisco
inmediatamente yo dije el primer día y
veía decía no esté todo el mundo iba
ayudar turismo de desastre yo le llames
no puede ser todo no quería ir y veía
siempre una toma del noticiero un
perrito al final ya sé cómo ayudó a la
gente ayudando a sus mascotas fui y de
repente llegó
maribel toledo de cuartopoder me acuerdo
y ustedes ya conocen un poco la historia
ahí
me conquistas te camarita y me di cuenta
del poder que teníamos los veterinarios
de vida me la creía yo quería tener el
superpoder de mi viejo ese superpoder lo
voy a utilizar con esa camarita y fue
así que un montón de gente empezó a
creer a escucharme
la gente me escucha
me gustó y dejé mi sueño de ser el mejor
traumatólogo y empecé a avanzar a
conquistar el mundo no porque cuando uno
joven quiere conquistar el mundo y con
toda la vehemencia y las ganas de decir
si yo tenía una deuda que todavía no se
haya contado con ser médico veterinario
con ese superpoder el de mi hermano
también tiene mucho que ver
él falleció atropellado
yo agarré y organice una caminata
contra el terrorismo vial
movilicé cielo y tierra
en regatas es un club exclusivo me
dejaron poner posters en regatas en
todos lados puse y al final logré
yo le dio un año no era
mi hermano hermano a mi voto
llegué
al
[Música]
por el mundo me dijo guau qué increíble
en la noche con velas alucinante y en la
noche tuve un sueño con él y me dijo
como me decía el no no sabes tú
eres veterinario a ti los animales te
importan
y ahí comenzó esa movida los animales me
importan eso que tantas satisfacciones
le ha dado hace 16 años l fabricio
unos motores
miren a lo que me dio
caminatas con la cantidad de gente yo no
podía creerlo yo siempre soñé de
chiquito
cantar con un montón de gente pero no
tengo la voz bueno acá yo canto detrás
de una canción que me lo hicieron con
mucho cariño así la suerte las
oportunidades que te da ser veterinario
yo canto pues con un montón de gente es
alucinante porque yo me pongo así la
gente es así y me pongo allá en lo caso
todo eso
mi obsesión de los animales me importan
yo ahora cuando cuento carros y el
tráfico hacía aburrido yo en el día
cuento 14 stickers 15 stickers 13 porque
no vi más que está pasando y
veterinarias tienen que ver los stickers
es como la s es superman o los animales
me importan es la s de los animales no
es parte de ese superpoder lo han visto
en carros los niños niños que me vieron
al inicio de mi carrera televisiva donde
cambiaron todos mis sueños
así cuánto 16 años 15 años cuando tenían
10 hoy tienen 25 hoy están votando hay
gente muchos de ustedes de repente han
crecido viéndome en la tele viendo los
animales importan y eso a mí me encanta
porque es parte de él
esa queja que voy a que voy a soltar
esta mochila que cada vez me pesa más la
voy a dejar hoy día acá
entro en la televisión entro hola a
todos entró matías vive un mundo que no
conocía pero era una oportunidad más
y ahí ustedes ya saben la historia
doctor bet michelle alexander pasear por
todos lados premios luces este guau
conocí el perú conocí el mundo
ese personaje no quién es
el encantador de perros' no me queda
atrapado una cueva ocho horas cruces
otra historia
eso ahí volví a nacer
pero la gente aplaudiendo motivándose
dije guau qué tal mensaje en el
veterinario tiene un superpoder ojo yo
soy bien emocionado para contar las
cosas todo eso me empezó a pasar
libros antes y mi último libro
veterinario literalmente en casa las
veterinarias reventando por todos lados
ahorita que vamos a abrir la quinta y
cada vez es alucinante vídeo guau qué
tal superpoder qué bestia gracias no ser
veterinario
si yo vuelvo a nacer volvería a ser
veterinario de todas maneras y miren lo
que me dio la televisión la comunicación
ese es el último
la última caminata que hubo más de
30.000 personas
alucinante después viendo la pandemia
bueno ahora saben que a los veterinarios
los 100 que involucran el primero que
detectó está este hobbit de todas
maneras un veterinario si fue una
enfermedad que viendo los animales a ojo
con eso
pero
y hoy día voy a hacer una confesión
porque hoy también es una oportunidad
para mí una gran oportunidad número uno
agradecerle a mis referentes y se los
digo
todos los que mencionaba en mi referente
son mis referentes
pero yo tengo una vergüenza grande que
venía a dejar la cama
yo estudié un colegio este particular
de los caros pero tenían la vergüenza
a mí me da vergüenza decir que mi viejo
era veterinario
lahey
ahora
lo que quiero es que mis hijos estén
orgullosos
de su viejo por ser veterinario y por
usar ese superpoder
hoy
tuve una gran oportunidad de esta charla
que la gente sepa que somos
importantísimos en la salud que si
queremos que no ocurra una pandemia una
salud es lo que se tiene que hacer la
salud se debe manejar de manera
multidisciplinaria con veterinarios con
biólogos con médicos y con todos con
ingenieros con todos todos debemos ser
parte de esto una salud check
oportunidad 2
observer se suicidó
que todos sepan que existe una
enfermedad mundial la depresión que
también afecta mucho a los médicos
veterinarios
afecta todos a
según estudios uno de cada seis
veterinarios han pensado suicidarse
porque los veterinarios son los
profesionales con mayor tasa de surgido
cuál es la profesión más suicida de eeuu
y nueva york cómo evitar el riesgo
porque los veterinarios existían tanto
la desgarradora historia de la
veterinaria
ella es doctor coss y ellas algún gato
en nueva york
gastó el oro en morro y de repente vino
alguien dijo es el mío movilizó a todo
el mundo las redes sociales se
convierten en terroristas órdenes
virtuales terminó suicidándose
la carga los veterinarios
tratamos y manejamos eutanasia la
tecnología de punta la eutanasia tenemos
el tema de la vida y la muerte
un poco distorsionado tenemos acceso a
eso
yo lo que les pido hoy
porque en mi oportunidad tengo ese
superpoder
recuerden que es ese poder que me dio mi
viejo hablo por ellos
por vos por los que se fueron
m
no no
es un movimiento que cada vez que tú lo
veas es porque alguien más está siendo
empático con los médicos veterinarios
otro estudio revela que más del 70% los
médicos veterinarios consultados se
siente siente cansancio y el 40% dijo
estar cansado emocionalmente
nosotros
dormimos
si tú recogiste al perro y no podemos
nosotros gastar porque hay familias
atrás no nos digas que no tenemos
ocasión no nos hagan bullying
empatía empatía
seamos empáticos
la reflexión
que hoy tengo es que hoy pude decirlo
me saqué esa mochila y hoy pude hablar
por ese referente por vos
ser veterinario para poder tener el
superpoder que tenía mi padre para
salvar vidas lo logré me la creí
créanselas
tener ese poder para entender que la
salud es única para todos y que se debe
manejar de manera
multidisciplinaria si no queremos que
vuelvan más pandemia ya estamos saliendo
tener ese superpoder para comunicar en
la televisión que el veterinario es un
profesional importante para la sociedad
es la mochila que yo estaba cargando y
hoy
esta es una gran oportunidad y por eso
se lo agradezco bastante
atp la muerte mi hermano que me motivó a
seguir adelante como veterinario y
generar movimientos como los animales me
importan
la oportunidad que ted
me ha dado para poder hacer esta charla
y hablar de tantas cosas de ese
superpoder que realmente
me mueve
me mueve mi carrera
me mueve porque es una carrera sensible
somos sensibles los veterinarios pues
somos sensibles siempre agradecer las
oportunidades van madurando no todas
aparecen a la misma vez no todas
aparecen cuando tú quieres actitud
ganadora de la actitud de ese superhéroe
yo me siento súper ebro
yo quiero que mi hijo me vea así que se
sienta orgulloso que no sea tan huevas
de pensar como yo yo no sabía que había
pensado en ese momento
todas las personas que son una
tienen una forma de ser una
pero que es increíble su forma de ser
también es increíble
seamos increíbles y creé tela todos
tenemos ese super poder gracias a esas
morales
gracias
y gracia del equipo
[Aplausos]